here's the good news I wanted to share
with you oh that's great this is stupid
so New York Times put out this article
that basically says being short is
better for the planet climate and the
climate and you should procreate like
tall people like me and George
um and Janna Gilbert we don't know about
you five now I'm short okay
um we should procreate with short people
because they you guys are inherent
conservationists if people were 10
shorter we would save 87 million tons of
food a few killing gallons of water
because because of consumption of the
body what the body can take um yeah you
less body to feed less waste well [__]
it let's all be dwarves then I mean what
the [__] you talking about well I think
so yeah yeah [__] a dwarf and when you
mate with a shorter person let's do the
campaign [__] a dwarf don't say that
just say [__] Brad Williams
so basically when you when you mate with
a shorter person you're potentially
saving the planet by like shrinking the
needs of subsequent Generations but all
I'm saying is you should put this new
article on your dating app
that would be funny oh you think I
should I think oh and you should not lie
about your height I don't lie about the
height
five three that's not true that's not
what you put on Tinder would you put six
I remember would I put it five five you
put like five five six or something no I
did I swear to God I didn't maybe five
yeah yeah um well I'm the only app I'm
on now is Raya I got banned from the
other one other ones all right so I
don't know what to do I think I'm gonna
get a new phone I think and I'm gonna
get I'm gonna redo it you have to but
with my real age this time but I'm
thinking now that like all of these
girls who have like height requirements
were like I only want to date a guy
who's like 5 10 and taller or six foot
tall like they're they're not great
conservationists like we should all be
[__] short dudes short Kings is the
way to go yeah yeah I've always thought
that and then you should be [__]
forefoot nine Ting Ting oh I should go
lower yeah you keep going tall oh so you
have to go lower as well oh I have to go
low or that's more of you that's hard
why can I go my height yeah yes yeah
that's that's good I'll go my height
you're hiding I can't go lower I've
never had sex with anyone lower
really no ever no I I just like you're
not all of it on me you're not into
doggie then what you're not into dog I
don't like doggy I like looking at the
face good yeah yeah I like looking in
the eyes and seeing your suffering
in your confusion he's going to see the
computer he goes yeah bye yeah yeah
you're my concubine you know welcome to
the potty baby
yeah the ticket my dick's a ticket
yeah but um
so if you're you're the guys that you're
seeing say that though
no I just read the article no no the
other before though oh
so
basically yes it's very apparent that
like if you call I'm always picking up
if he text like I'm always attending to
you first like we're here and we're here
in Hawaii say for instance like you're
getting my master bedroom I'm sleeping
on the couch like you're always gonna be
first like